Resuelve para "z" y tenemos "5z" más 7 menor que 27
ó "-3z" menor o igual que 18.
Así que este problema que nos piden resolver
es un problema de desigualdades compuestas,
tenemos dos restricciones para nuestra "z",
tenemos que encontrar todos los valores posibles
para los cuales, alguna de estas dos condiciones se cumplen o puede ser que se cumplan ambas
al mismo tiempo, ok.
Entonces esencialmente lo que vamos a hacer
es resolver cada una por separado
y después vamos a unir las soluciones...
es decir, vamos a considerar ambos conjuntos
como una solución global.
Muy bien, entonces lo que tenemos de la primera
desigualdad, vamos a ponerla, esto es "5z"
más 7 menor que 27, muy bien, entonces lo
que podemos hacer de ambos lados es restar
7, para irnos... para ir despejando nuestra
"z" y aquí por supuesto se cancelan y me quedan
"5z" y esto debe ser menor que 27 menos
7 que son simplemente 20.
Muy bien, entonces, ahora para poder despejar
la "z" necesitamos dividir todo entre 5 de
ambos lados y la desigualdad no cambia debido
a que estamos dividiendo entre un número
positivo, si hubiera sido negativo entonces
si se tiene que invertir, pero en este caso
no, porque 5 es un número positivo y eso
es ya muy bueno que lo tengamos muy presente,
así que del lado izquierdo lo que me va a
quedar es "z"
y del lado derecho me queda 20 entre 5, que son 4.
Entonces aquí tenemos nuestra primera condición
que podría cumplir "z".
Vamos a ver que pasa del otro lado, tenemos
"-3z" es menor o igual que 18.
Muy bien, entonces, esto es muy inmediato
porque lo que tenemos que hacer es dividir
entre 3, pero hay que tener mucho cuidado,
hay que tener mucho cuidado porque en este
caso si estamos dividiendo entre un número
negativo, así que en este caso como dividimos
entre un número negativo la desigualdad se
invierte y ahora tenemos mayor o igual.
Muy bien, entonces, ¿qué es lo que tenemos?
"-3z" entre -3 simplemente es "z", que es
mayor o igual que 18 entre -3, que es -6...
-6, así que nuestras dos condiciones las podemos resumir estas dos en que "z" es menor que 4
ó "z" es mayor o igual que -6, ok y entonces esto es sumamente, sumamente interesante
y para qué es lo que está ocurriendo vamos, vamos a ver que es lo que ocurriría en la recta real.
Así que vamos a poner... uy... un poquito
más derechita...
yo creo que con esto sirve...
Muy bien, ahí tenemos nuestra recta donde se encuentran colocados todos los números reales,
digamos que por aquí anda el 0, el 1, el 2, el 3 y el 4, éste es el que si me interesa
y nos vamos hacia atrás en -1, -2,
-3, -4, -5 y -6, muy bien, aquí están los
números que ya dije, pues aquí sería por
ejemplo -7 acá anda el 5, en fin, entonces
nuestro primer conjunto digamos "z" menor
que 4, "z" menor que 4,
entonces no vamos a incluir el 4, vamos a dejar la bolita abierta, pero todo lo que está a la izquierda del 4,
si lo vamos a tomar... si vamos a tomar todo lo que está a la izquierda del 4.
Muy bien, ésta es una parte de mi conjunto
solución, cualquiera que sea menor que 4,
es una solución a este conjunto de desigualdades
porque es un "o" y si satisface al menos una,
con eso basta.
Ahora bien, del otro lado tenemos que "z"
debe ser mayor o igual que -6,
entonces el -6 lo incluimos y nos tomamos todo lo que
esté a la derecha de -6.
Muy bien, incluso el 4 verdad, el 4 está a la derecha de -6, entonces como puedes darte cuenta
tomamos toda la línea, toda la línea, cualquier punto en la línea real cumple
ya sea la primera condición
o la segunda o ambas, ¿no?
Por ejemplo, que pasa con el 0, el 0 está
justo en ambas, 5 por 0 es 0 más 7,
claramente si es menor que 27 y -3 por 0 es 0 que claramente también es 18, entonces pueden satisfacer
una condición, por ejemplo el 4, el 4 va
a cumplir que -3 por 4 es -12 que es si es
menor o igual que 18, pero si multiplicamos
aquí por 4, es 5 por 4 = 20 más 7 es 27
y no es cierto que 27 sea menor estricto que 27, es exactamente igual, entonces como puedes
darte cuenta hay números que cumplen alguna
condición o puede ser que cumplan ambas,
lo que si es cierto es que toda la recta real,
satisface alguna o ambas condiciones.